borland qu'est ce que c'est beau la
langue ça c'est vous et spécialistes ça
c'est le spin off de fort boyard quatre
émissions est étonné pour une diffusion
cet hiver est là ce sera deux équipes de
quatre personnalités qui vont
s'affronter dans des épreuves ludiques
dans l'univers de la fête foraine dans
l'univers de la fête foraine fouras du
père fouras bien sûr voici les images on
en parle juste après
fort boyard c'est devenu le game of
thrones à la française
ça cartonne et france 2 a même décidé de
produire un spin off de l'émission
spéciale hiver ça d un nouveau programme
centré autour d'un personnage
emblématique du fort alors lequel passe
partout oui bon d'accord ce sera
l'incontournable père fouras le tournage
commencera en septembre et sera intitulé
boyard landes
il s'effectuera sur la mythique plage du
lys chantilly en région parisienne
l'émission reviendra sur le passé du
père fouras il y a trente ans lorsqu'il
dirigeait un parc d'attractions
au casting également de nouveaux
personnages après passe partout on
découvrira passe nulle part pas si vite
le cousin de basse muraille pas si drôle
le clone du parc passe moi le sucre la
première femme naine du jeu double passe
deux soeurs siamoises mais aussi
monsieur moustache ou encore madame
barbe des nouveautés à découvrir
prochainement sur france 2
alors alors les longs qu'on a entendu
c'est sépare c'est un géant qui fait de
maître de mettre 35 passes molles succès
là c'est un personnage de femme de sa
vie au nom de s'arrêter non quand même
pas qu est ce qu il yad autres alors
doublé pas sur moi je vais pas accès
alors évidemment gym il est choqué par
ces noms là c'est grotesque voilà ce
souvenir main quel est l'intérêt déjà
que fort boyard est poussif là on nous
nous avons des noms à sa tire en
longueur on nous avions guennic invités
c'est vous dire
[Applaudissements]
c'est une émission pouces et blanc ont
fait il est un spin off on sait même pas
ce que c'est on invente une nouvelle
émission d'alors est en ruine avec des
nombreux bus alors ridicule même pas un
affront deux chaussées de un gilles et
jaloux puisque il a germé été invités
d'en faire deux ils ne parlent pas
anglais apparemment spin off ça lui
parle pas mais y'a plein de vous lasser
les deux aussi faisait off c'est en fait
c'est un autre version ce n'est la suite
il ya dix ans moi je trouve vraiment que
tu es gonflé gilles parce que nous
déjeunons minable sur passe-partout
personne n'en a fait douze mille alors
on aurait franchement se moquer de ce
alors que nous on a fait pire est
vraiment foutage de gueule
en tout cas là cela montre encore que
français de vision veut toujours
renouvelé son divertissement
voilà déjà dix ans que ça il ya une
polémique et abandonné sur le le nom sur
les personnes de petite taille on doit
pas dire un homme n'y a pas une
politique non sur l'accord qu'il avait
eue sur le csa c'était qu'il y avait
c'était sur le lancer de nains wimax oui
mais apprécions les non non non non pas
plus que ça se passe partout ça passe
passe pathos